And now the old scout master.
Hey, Clark Woodhunter, here,
Don't mean to bust your chops, but being a Minnesotan,
I gotta teach you how to say E-lee properly,
Not E-lee, E-lee,
That's how that northern tier is.
And I tell you what you need to come up some winter
and take your boys up there,
because it's an awesome program in the winter.
It has become a yearly event for our boys now
as it's a progressively more advanced every time you go.
Have a great day, great show, Thanks Bye.
So after all this, I probably won't pronounce E-lee wrong again.
Yeah,
It's just good there's no high adventure bases
in Faribault or Cloquet or Waseka
or Lutzen or Aiken or Bemidji,
and especially that there's not one up there on Kabatoga in the lake,
because, boy, that'd be hard to pronounce now, wouldn't it?
Yep, yeah, Okay, then
This is podcast number 137..
You betcha?
So there you go then.
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Hey, it sure is good to hear from the folks up in Minnesota.
It puts me in mind of this.
We're getting ready to go to Switzerland- last year, right,
And we have a bunch of scouts ready to go
and we're talking to them about you know,
a little bit about international travel
and what they can expect,
and that we said that people would be very interested
in speaking to them because they're from the United States
and they have this accent that people hear in all the movies.
And they kind of looked at us
and they said: we don't have accents,
So we've all got one,
and that's one of the best things about it all, isn't it?
Yeah, you betcha.
So let's take a look at the mailbag
Now. David Copeland wrote in.
I had a four-hour drive on Friday
and got a chance to catch up on the podcast.
I enjoyed the 10 ways to support the senior patrol leader,
and that was a couple of podcasts ago, I think 135..
Thank you very much, David.
I'm glad you're finding that useful.
Bill McFarland wrote in about our last podcast,
Podcast 136,
and we had a Scoutmaster panel discussion
with Life Scout Enoch,
who gave us an interesting perspective
of being a scout and working with adult leaders,
And Bill said this:
He said kudos to Enoch for trying something different.
There's nothing more than a troop
that just does the same thing over and over again.
It's too bad that his troop did not have the choice
to reelect him as the senior patrol leader.
Although I've never set term limits.
there have been times I wish the senior patrol leader
would run for office again.
And then, as a counterpoint,
Bucky Collins wrote in and said this:
He says it's understandable.
Good leadership has always appreciated
The senior patrol leader he mentioned.
Enoch is doing a fine job, no doubt,
but the time is actually really short
and all those who are qualified
should be given a chance at the position.
You don't want to let leadership abilities wane
just because he doesn't have the top post anymore.
He can still be involved in another leadership role.
It's all too easy for a troop to slide
into this deceptive, comfortable position
of fixed leadership
where the same people are leading over and over again,
When all the time what we need to be doing
is filling our ranks with new recruits.
Many a time in my youth,
the kind of click mentality that kept
the guys in leadership for a long time
ruined a perfectly good troop or a post.
A unit always has to be bringing in new members
to stay fresh and vibrant.
My beloved old troop
recently folded after 47 years.
At the end we had more skilled adult
and young adult leaders
and only two younger scouts.
so we always need to be recruiting.
While Bucky does, there are good thoughts,
and I don't know that there's a right
or a wrong way to deal with this.
I think it depends on where the troop is.
If you have a whole lot of younger scouts
and a couple of older scouts,
well, maybe those older scouts end up
in a leadership position a little bit longer than usual.
If you have some real go-getters
amongst those younger scouts, hey,
they may need to move right into
those big leadership positions.
You got to read what's on the ground
and, as has been advised here,
you don't want to fall into a rut.
just because we elect a senior patrol leader
every six months or every year
doesn't mean that we can't revisit that
tradition of doing things.
You know, we'll need to look over the edge of the rut
and see what's actually happening on the ground
and read that.
I think that's a pretty important thing to do.
I'm a big fan of getting a broad perspective
on exactly what's going on.
Try new stuff.
Don't get caught in traditions
that turn into kind of bad habits over time.
This podcast is an interview
with author Mike Malone,
and a lot of you would be familiar
with his new book 4%,
A History of the Eagle Scout Award.
It's a fascinating read and it's a great book
and I really enjoyed talking to Mike
and I know you'll enjoy listening.
One thing Mike mentions in the interview
is another book called The Scouting Party,
and I wanted to mention this because
there is a review of The Scouting Party
and also an interview with the author of that book
in a past podcast,
and I'll have a link in the post
that contains Podcast 137,
this podcast-
so that you can find that book.
If you're a fan of scouting history-
The Scouting Party-
It's a real good read too.
I know a lot of you have gotten the Kindle edition
of 4%
and I have had lots
and lots of questions about
when it will come out as a regular old book
that you can put on a bookshelf,
and Mike's going to answer that question
for us best he can in the interview.
So that's going to take up
the remainder of the podcast.
so let's get started, shall we
Music?
So? friend of the blog and podcast. Michael
Esmalone
is one of the world's best known
technology writers.
He was twice nominated for the Pulitzer Prize
for investigative reporting
and you've read his articles and editorials
like The Wall Street Journal, The Economist,
Fortune and The New York Times.
He's the author and co-author
of nearly 20 award winning books.
Mike is,
all importantly, an Eagle Scout
and currently an assistant scout
master of Troop 466
in Sunnyvale, California.
Now, in this centennial year of 2012-
that's centennial year of the Eagle Scout-
Mike turned his considerable talent
as an investigative reporter and writer,
as well as his extensive
experience as a scout and adult volunteer,
towards
a book that no doubt will stand,
at least in my humble opinion,
as the definitive history
of the Eagle Scout award. It's called
4%
and subtitled the story of Uncommon Youth
in a Century of American Life.
I think it's not only
an authoritative history of the award,
but it's kind of a meditation on the meaning
and the spirit and importance of it,
and I'm certainly honored to welcome to the podcast.
Thanks for joining us, Mike.
Well, thank you, Clair.
So in the first chapter of the book,
you call the Eagle the PhD of
boyhood. Yeah, I heard that along
the way somewhere a few years ago
and I thought it was a brilliant
metaphor
for what
Eagle Scouting is, That it's
a combination of
learned skills combined
with a
final culminating
event, which is the Eagle Service project
that has to contribute to the larger
world, And if you look at
that way, it really is like a doctorate
and there's nothing comparable
to it in American boyhood.
that never has been,
and it's really
the apogee
of being a teenage boy
in the United States and it's been that way for
a hundred years now. What I really
enjoy about the book- because it's a great
read, because it's a
fantastic story.
Just the story of how
this award came to be
and who has received it
and what they went on to do is just a fascinating
story And I think
in one wise the history of the award itself
is a history
of the Boy Scouts of America.
We were talking just a little bit before we started
the interview here that that history
has its ups and downs
and its bumps and its troubles.
That's one of the things I really appreciate about your work.
It doesn't dodge any of those issues.
It's very honest. Did you
struggle with any of that?
Yeah, when I set out to write this book,
I'm a
lifelong newspaper man journalist.
I'm a fourth generation
newspaper man. In fact
I'm sitting here editing some copy from my
21 year old son who is now a fifth generation
family
newspaper man. So it's in the blood
And it was very hard for me to
even contemplate the idea
of great washing the story or turning into
a hagiography
of the March of Great Men.
That's just not my style.
I think the story is much more
interesting when you capture awards and all,
And it's not like Scouting has a lot
of awards. I mean, it's a
inspiring story all the way through
And, yeah, there have been
some missteps and
trips down the wrong path
a few times, But all in all
I think those
other things, those darker things,
actually make the entire story
much more spectacular,
much more amazing. It's an awe
inspiring story. Now it really
is. And you know,
those bright moments are offset by the
not so bright ones.
Let me tell you the genesis of this
book, because it's kind of unusual.
I had taken a group of
scouts from my troop back to
northern Virginia.
Two of the boys were
restoring a Civil War
battlefield and
cemetery, which sounds
hugely ambitious And it was,
even though these are the two smallest
battlefields
and federal cemeteries in the United States
and Balls Bluff.
But it was quite an experience doing this
and as part of it we were
going to be in the flag
ceremony in our Civil War uniforms
at
the National Jamboree And
we also marched in the Centennial
Parade of Boy Scouting
down Pennsylvania Avenue in Washington DC
and I think there was
20,000 scouts in that parade.
It was quite a parade. It was the first one of this kind
since
the first jamboree before FDR.
I was in the contingent at the very
end which was Eagle Scouts,
and each of us
was asked to
carry or wear something that represented
our career. So I had the notebook,
I had the satchel over my shoulder
with the press card. But I looked
around me and there were
guys dressed as department stores,
Santa Claus. There was a guy
from Bermuda who was a diplomat.
There was
a military officer and he was wearing the
full Hurt Locker bomb demolition
outfit- which was pretty tough
because it was 100 degrees that day-
Just a panoply
of distinguished
middle-aged and older
men showing the
wares of these
remarkable careers that had followed
becoming Eagle Scouts.
And we started down that parade-
and I was afraid a few of us weren't going to make it
in that heat. They were 80-year-olds, with us
marching at the tail end of
this massive parade of Boy Scouts.
We turned the corner
and started heading down towards the
Washington Monument And as we
did, the loudspeaker shouted out:
ladies and gentlemen,
this is Eagle Scouts.
And the roar
that came up from the crowd- there was probably
50 or 60,000 people lining that
mile of
avenue there, The roar that came up
for these Eagles
and looking at these old guys, you know, with bad
hips and glimping and all that.
And we all stood a whole lot
straighter and
marched in formation
And I suddenly was struck
by the relationship between
Eagle Scouts and American culture
And that story
had never really been explored
And I just
had to write the book at that point.
It was an insane idea
because I was buried in
a new start-up technology company
and writing other books
and teaching college.
But I just had to write the book because
I realized nobody else was going to do it.
There were no real plans
for the 100th anniversary of Eagle Scouting,
So I decided to do the celebration myself
And you know the result
shows the passion that you had for it.
Yeah, it's kind of a book that wrote itself.
I tore through this one.
Some books are very painful to write.
Spending
three years writing about Steve Jobs once
was not the happiest time of my life,
But writing this book
my fingers worked
by themselves. If we asked everybody
who the first Eagle Scout was,
they'd probably come up with Arthur Eldred.
But there's a lot more to
that story
And there's a lot more nuance and depth to it.
First, tell me about the time
that Arthur was a scout
and what was going on
at that point
in the history of the BSA.
Yeah, let me preface that by saying
we all know it's Arthur Eldred,
But 15,, 20 years ago
I think, if you
asked people who the first Eagle Scout was,
nobody would know. I don't think the BSA
was quite certain.
That was a fact from basically the
20s until the 90s
that people didn't really know
about Arthur Eldred until I think it was
Boy's Life. our scouting magazine
went out to find who it was
And even then they got the wrong photo.
For a number of years
there was this square-jawed kid
out of a poster
who everyone thought was Arthur Eldred,
And finally
they found real photos of the guy,
just like every other Eagle Scout
you've ever known in your life,
Kind of skinny, smart-looking
and a bit amused
having to pose for the photograph.
You can really empathize.
He's us. Arthur Eldred is us,
except he's kind of more
than the rest of us given his career.
He got his Eagle in 1912
and you have to understand
that scouting didn't begin
as a monolithic organization.
It flows out of multiple organizations
like Daniel Boone Society,
various other groups.
It starts out
as basically a fad
among teenage boys.
They hear about Boy Scouts in England
and they start their own groups
and they turn into troops
and they turn into
these sort of ad hoc organizations.
There were about four or five
different Boy Scouts organizations
in the first decade
of the 20th century.
They were all over the place.
and if you ever
want to read the whole history of it
or read the Scouting Party,
which is the story of these early days
and the clashes of egos
of the different founders and all of that,
Arthur Eldred was a boy living on Long Island.
His father had died.
His mother was concerned,
like mothers today,
that without a dad he would get in trouble.
He had an older brother
who was quite a bit older,
so he stepped in
as his surrogate dad
and helped raise him.
This older brother
looked around and saw these emerging
Scouting groups
and thought
why don't I build one of these groups
with Arthur in it,
and that will give structure to his life?
He went out and actually set out
to join another Scouting organization,
One that's long gone now,
but it was much more
a touristic organization.
They carried guns around, they marched
and they were sort of like preparing boys
to join the Army
because it's not a bad thing to do
in 1910, given the clouds
forming over Europe.
but he had trouble getting
permission to start
the organization or something
and instead he said: okay, well,
there's this other outfit
headquartered down in Manhattan,
why don't we join up with them?
and that's America.
So they started this troop out on Long Island
and the boys did the usual stuff.
they didn't have a lot of money
they sort of
pulled their dough for
to buy uniforms. some of them didn't have uniforms.
it was very, very casual.
it was sort of closer to Baden Powell's
dream of what Scouting was
than what we think of today
of 60 member scout troops
meeting in a church gymnasium
with a trailer full of stuff
and all of that, and this was boys meeting
in the evening and like in a barn
or something.
and Arthur. at the time
there was very few
documentation on how
to be a Boy Scout.
there weren't really any ranks at the time.
it was all in development
and so
when the
first Boy Scout handbook appeared,
boys across America-
there was probably
1000 boys across the United States
that were involved in the organization at that time.
they gobbled up that book
because it not only showed them all the Scouting skills.
I mean, they had been dealing,
working with Baden Powell's old book
and various other books
about the outdoors. now they had an official book
and they went at it,
they consumed it
and began earning the various ranks.
and the ranks were kind of what they are today,
up until first class.
so you had 10% class
up until first class
and then it all kind of went crazy
because there were merit badges,
but there was only about 15 merit badges
and they were divided in two different categories.
there was sort of like an outdoor category
and then there was the home
and citizenship category
and you either earned
the star or the life.
they weren't sequential,
they were kind of in opposition.
and then there was this thing called the Eagle Scout Award
and this was the first time these boys
have ever seen it,
and Boy Scouts didn't give a lot of information,
they just sort of said
you had to have a certain number of merit badges.
and they had a drawing
of the Eagle Medal
and it was
very different from what we think of as the Eagle Medal.
it was a straight ribbon
with one color, monochromatic.
they didn't know what color it was.
it was a black and white book
and an eagle in flight flying sideways,
and that's all they knew.
they didn't get to the Eagle yet
available, but Boy Scouts
promised they'd have more.
so that's kind of where things stood.
so all across America, boys were earning these ranks.
well, Arthur Elder was one of these singular characters
and
he sort of
is the embodiment
of what we think of as that overachieving Eagle Scout.
Eagle Scouts are inevitably.
I've mentored about 50 of them.
I know you have mentored probably at least that many.
these kids
are focused and they,
they go for it.
and if Scouting had said you have to have 150 merit badges,
we still have Eagle Scouts
because these are the kinds of young men
who are goal oriented
and they'll do it. whatever it takes,
however many hours,
how much blood, sweat and tears,
they'll get there.
well, Arthur saw the number
of the 21 merit badges,
which was even true then,
and went out and got as many merit badges
as possible get.
and then, when Scouting finally announced
the next set of merit badges,
he went out and got those
and he got them at a pace that is
unprecedented
and will never again be equal.
at one point,
as near as I can figure, when he had about
17 or 18 merit badges,
he had more merit badges,
I believe, than
all the other Scouts in the United States.
so it's sort of like Babe Ruth.
you know, Babe Ruth in the early 1920s
one year had more home runs
than the entire rest of the American League.
well, that's kind of what Arthur Elder
was like 15 years before that.
he just
simply fell in love
with getting merit badges and he got them all.
well,
now he had a problem
because no one knew what he was supposed to do next,
including the voice Scouts of America.
so
they said: well, you have to have approval
for all of this from your local leaders.
so he went around
and
got letters of recommendation
from all the local
civic figures in his town in Long Island
and he sent those in.
well, at this point Scouting
was rocked on its heels
because it had not expected this to happen.
Scouting has a tendency to
announce these major new initiatives
and then is surprised
when these overachieving voice Scouts
earn these things
long before the institutions prepared for them.
he finishes the eagle,
he notifies scout headquarters
in Manhattan
and all hell breaks with people:
oh no,
we weren't even expecting an eagle for 5 more years.
and this kid comes along
and he's got it.
what are we going to do now?
they invite him down
to New York City
and they give him
a border review
and obviously this is the institution saying
we better make sure this kid
is actually for real because
we're going to have to announce him as the first eagle
scout in history
and we hope he's presentable.
so they bring him down
and they put him into
a border review with the founders of Scouting-
all of them.
we wear medals named after him,
like the
voice award
and all the rest of these guys,
these legends,
and somehow he went into this
border review
and came out alive.
it must have been very much like a star chamber.
I don't think any eagle scout- I'm sure
no other eagle scout in history-
had to face a border review like this one.
well, is this?
am I right?
do I remember reading that Ernest Thompson Seton
is on this board?
Ernest Thompson Seton and Dan Boyd
hated each other
because they had invented the two
founding organizations that became Boy Scouts.
that, in fact,
the Brits
had copied.
the original book on the outdoors
was the one that Baden Powell lifted from
to create
the original Boy Scout handbook.
so these middle-aged men sitting there
facing Arthur Eldred had all sorts of
access to grind
and feuds against each other
and everything else.
so to my mind,
as impressive as Arthur Eldred's
achievement earning all those merri-patches-
was surviving
that group.
that may have
qualified him more than anything else.
he must have been an amazing negotiator.
so he walks out
the very first eagle scout.
well,
now Scouting's got another problem.
nobody ever made the medal.
they've got a drawing.
that's literally all they have
is the drawing in the Boy Scout handbook,
and so
and so Boyd has to send a note
to Arthur Eldred saying
the medal isn't ready yet.
can you wait until fall?
so what's Eldred going to do?
fine, yes, I'll wait until fall.
well,
while he's waiting,
he's got the Boy Scout camp
with his troop,
and in the middle of this camp
they're swimming in a lake.
one of the boys starts to drown.
Eldred goes in after him,
along with another scout,
to save the kid.
well, as often happens,
as they teach you in life-saving,
as you remember,
people that go in to save people
sometimes get into stress themselves.
so Arthur goes in.
but now he's got the other kid
who's starting to drown,
and so he saves him too.
so we have this amazing
character
who earns more merit badges
than anybody in all the Boy Scouts
combined.
he then survives the star chamber
with the founders of Scouting
for his border review.
then, while he's waiting to get his award,
he earns the honor medal
for life-saving twice.
and this is all in the course of
a summer.
so Arthur had a pretty good year.
come fall,
they finally give him the Eagle medal
and it's completely different
than the one in the book.
thank goodness
because we end up with-
you can see the medal right now.
even now it's in the museum
in the Boy Scout Museum in Texas.
they give him the medal that looks
almost exactly like the one we all wear now.
Arthur Eldridge a remarkable man
and
goes on
and stays involved
all the way up through the 30s
and sits on boards of reviews.
he becomes a very
well, he's going to be like Neil Armstrong.
he's going to do
huge things.
once again he embodies
what being an Eagle Scout is.
he becomes this responsible,
trusted citizen.
he sits on various civic committees.
he sits on
his job is on these various
industrial boards
for quality and that sort of thing.
just lives a solid,
honest life of a good citizen
and gets back involved in scouting.
and his son becomes an Eagle Scout
and there's a picture
of Arthur
in his 50s-
great hair and giving the award
to his son.
the line of Eldridge ever since
has earned Eagle Scouts.
I think we're fourth or fifth generation Eldridge now
with Eagle Men
and then he.
but after he earns the medal
in 1912 he just sort of fades
from scouting history
until
50, 60 years later they begin to,
like a lot of institutions,
they don't start thinking about their history
until they have some major milestone
and scouting at its 50th anniversary,
really begin to think about its past
and start to try to document it
and discovered it had lost a lot of its records
and it took a while to find
it was Arthur
and then it took even longer to actually find a photo of him.
every honor he gets he deserves.
he's an amazing person.
well, he kind of invented the Eagle.
in some ways,
what he did, he was
just as much an inventor of it as anybody else.
it seems.
oftentimes these individuals,
they force institutions
to respond to them
and in doing so
they drive the definition of
what something is.
I'm going to break into just a moment
to give you an update on the stuff
adult leaders say:
t-shirt. if you haven't heard about this,
go over to scoutmastercgcom
and follow the link that says a t-shirt.
just for us. it's a Kickstarter project
and we're doing really great.
we have 13 days left to go,
we have 30% funded,
we have 35 backers,
and I wanted to say thank you to all those
who've backed the project on Kickstarter
and all of you who have sent in ideas
about exactly what should go on the t-shirt.
it's been a lot of fun
and let's keep it going.
the project closes in a little less than two weeks
and I can't offer any more t-shirts after that.
the only way to get one
is to make sure you get over and make a pledge,
and there's a link to get you there
at scoutmastercgcom.
so thanks very much once again, folks,
for participating. and let's get back to
the interview.
Arthur's story
of going on
kind of leads into the idea that
by the 1920s
these boys who were earning Eagle Scout
they would become 18,
they would age out of the organization.
but there was some response
to that.
it resulted in
an organization that used to be
very well known,
but I don't know that anybody really knows about it anymore:
the Knights of Dunamis.
how did that all come about?
and you're talking to one of the last surviving knights.
really,
there aren't many of us left.
I got my Eagle very young
and I became a Knight of Dunamis,
I think, when I was
16 or 17,
stayed until I was 21
and that was
the early 1970s,
and it was basically an organization
to take Eagle Scouts
and to organize them and use them
to perform service to scouting
and to the community,
not really from the time you became an Eagle,
but usually from the time you left your troop
and you joined a chapter
and ultimately there was about 50 chapters
or 100 chapters around the United States,
several thousand members.
I was a chapter president in San Jose
in the late 60s,
early 70s and we did everything from
Honor Guard and the Cinco de Mayo
parade to putting on children's
Christmas shows
and hospitals
to holding probably
100 Eagle Court of Honor
with our robes on and all that.
so it was really a remarkable organization
that did a tremendous amount of things.
amazing organization-
it's what really made me think
of myself as an Eagle Scout.
but by the 1970s
and 80s it was fading.
scouting gave it one last chance
and by then it was too late
and so I found myself at the
1973 National Jamboree
in Pennsylvania standing in front of
about 10,000
Eagle Scouts
announcing the death. I was part of the program.
I announced the death of the Knights of Dunamis
and the founding of the National Eagle Scout Association
and you are-
you're still involved in that.
yeah, I'm the president of the local NISA chapter,
much more structured than the Knights of Dunamis was.
I missed the old Knights of Dunamis
and my hope is that
NISA, as it develops,
will become more
like that, more service oriented,
become an institution itself,
and I think the first really good step
was the creation of the Adams Award,
which is that award for the best
Eagle project in the United States.
that's a pretty recent thing, yeah,
yeah, it's just three years old
and, remarkably enough,
the oldest son
earned the first Adams Award.
he won the award for the western region.
he basically got a bunch of
Silicon Valley CEOs
and VCs to buy a 50 foot
shipping container. he filled it full of about
three schools worth of supplies
and sent it off to
Children's Town, AIDS Orphanage
and school in Zambia, where we had
visited, and it's turned into.
the container itself was turned into a library.
so I mean this is a glimpse of
21st century Eagle projects. look like
there's a good section of the book
about these awards and things
which you know are fairly new
and not a whole lot of people really know about.
but what was the genesis of the Eagle project?
you didn't always do a project
to become an Eagle Scout.
no, and in fact you know,
you always ran into these old Eagle Scouts.
I was much tougher back in the old days.
nobody had as hard as we did getting our Eagle.
there's a little bit of truth to that.
earning an Eagle in the 1920s
or 30s or 40s
was actually not that difficult,
except for one Maripatch,
and that was bird study.
nobody got that Maripatch.
there are thousands of elderly
men who will tell you
that they never got the Eagle because they couldn't pass
bird study. but in terms of the overall
requirements, modern scouting is much more
difficult and that has to do with the Eagle project.
there was a feeling that
because scouting was growing so fast
during the baby boomer era that a lot of kids
were getting their Eagles but not really getting
deep into scouting, so there was a requirement
for participation
and then community service,
and they still exist.
then in the early 60s it was decided
that no, that wasn't enough.
what we wanted the Eagles to do
was to take all the skills that they had learned
and to
apply them in some organized way
that required them to have a plan,
a project
and exhibit the skills of being a leader
dealing with adults.
and that was the beginning
of the Eagle service project.
you know, you talk to somebody who got their Eagle
in the late 60s and they say, what was your Eagle project?
and they say, oh, I don't really remember.
I think we painted some benches at the park
and that was a very
successful Eagle project
back in the late 60s.
but we have 300,000
teenage boys each year
performing
or creating real, honest, to goodness
social enterprises,
doing social entrepreneurship
and changing the face of this country.
and because these tend to be
discrete, comparatively
small events,
they get coverage in the local paper
but no one puts it all together
and says: good lord,
these Eagle scouts
are the single most
important force of-
I don't know what you call it-
social improvement in the United States,
and it's all in time.
you quoted in the book
the figure ten and a half million hours.
is that right?
ten and a half million hours a year
on Eagle projects?
and if you add it up over the history of Eagle scouting,
we're looking at about a hundred to a hundred and fifty million hours
of
civic contribution,
which makes it the largest service project
by youth
in history.
just amazing what these kids are doing nowadays.
yeah, from the small to the big,
they all add up into this
incredible force.
yes, they absolutely do.
yeah, it's just amazing.
we recently marked the passing
of Neil Armstrong,
who's got to be probably
arguably the most famous
Eagle Scout.
yeah, it's Neil Armstrong.
and I'm in a weird position
of I think I'm the last person
who worked with Neil Armstrong.
really,
yeah, because
when we had the book in draft,
we got access to
to Dr Armstrong
and I asked him: I've written this chapter about you,
but I'm not sure it's accurate.
would you check it out?
and he was famously prickly about not
dealing with the media,
not doing any publicity,
and at one point I made the mistake of asking
if he'd give me a jacket quote. and I got it immediate:
no, I don't do that.
but
he did go over the chapter
and I thought: well, it'll take a few weeks.
you know we're coming up on deadline. it's going to be close.
24 hours later he sent me back
three pages of email
correcting every little detail.
so I'm sitting in my house
emailing back and forth
with Neil Armstrong, which was
pretty mind boggling.
and then I realized
a week later when it was announced that he had gone in for heart surgery,
that he had literally finished editing
his chapter for me like
48 hours before he went to the hospital
and I'm sure he assumed he was coming out.
oh my gosh,
or I can't believe that he would have devoted the time to this
if he thought it was that serious.
so
I put a little note
on the bottom of that chapter.
but yeah, it's
quite an amazing thing and you know, once again,
sort of an eagle scout
being helpful.
the book has just dozens of
different stories
about eagles who went on to distinguish themselves
in various ways,
and some of them used to be
pretty much household names
and you bring them back to memory.
and one that I wanted to ask you to talk about a little bit
is Paul Syple.
he's a very interesting guy
and you could argue until
Neil Armstrong comes on the scene.
the shiny example of what an eagle scout is
was Paul Syple. for
40 years,
the middle era of scouting.
he's the man.
he's another remarkable guy.
I mean you read this and you
look at your own
when you put on your eagle medal, you think, wow,
am I worthy to wear the medal
that Neil Armstrong and Arthur Eldred and Paul Syple wore.
Syple
is sort of the ultimate eagle scout.
when you think of an eagle scout,
he's a great big guy,
a toothy grin,
everyone-
a natural leader-
earned his eagle, I think, when he was 18 or 18 and a half.
in those days, if you were on your way to eagle,
you were allowed to go on
and finish it. after your 18th birthday
it was already accepted into college.
I think he had 30 merit badges.
he had done a lot of
50 milers and he was the real deal.
Commodore Perry is going to
go to the South Pole
and he publicly announced
that he was going to take
one eagle scout
with him to Antarctica
and he was going to have a national competition.
well, Syple hears about it
and applies.
he's.
the list is swiddled down to
10 or 12 boys,
all of them super overachievers
from around the country. the stories covered
in every paper in America. it's a very big deal.
Syple shines above
all of these other overachievers
and Perry agrees to take him.
his plan is: he's going to go along
and he's going to go on the ship,
sailing down there and working
the galley and
by the time they get to Antarctica
he's already moved out of the galley,
he's up on deck and he's starting
to take care of the animals
and he turns out to be incredibly
strong
and more capable than the
professionals that Perry's brought with him
and as a result, he ends up being
Perry's number two guy
two months.
he's just this amazing guy
and everybody loves him
because he's such a nice guy.
by the time it's over, he's Perry's protege
and when he comes back he goes to college
and he's celebrated
and feted and all that.
Perry goes down again. he's going to fly over to South Pole.
he invites
Syple to be his guy,
to go with him down there to do it,
and so Syple slowly becomes,
especially as Perry gets older.
Syple becomes the world's leading
art explorer
and he not only begins to explore
Antarctica but also the Arctic.
and when
World War II breaks out,
he's doing scientific research
and they ask him to investigate
different kinds of
weather systems,
environments for soldiers to fight in
and what kind of uniforms they need, and all that.
and while he's at it,
he invents the notion of windshield
factor.
so whenever you hear windshield factor,
it's in front of an NFL football game.
that's Paul Syple too,
and he just becomes
one of the greatest applied scientists
America has ever produced.
for long as I've been involved in this guy-
no doubt as long as you've been involved-
there's always been a lot of
discussions that
tend to turn into arguments
about what constitutes an eagle scout.
people can get pretty
exercised about it.
you've
had an interesting perspective
of that question.
is there an answer?
there's simple answers and there's complicated answers.
the simple answer is
being an eagle scout state of mind.
one of the amazing things about the eagle award is
it's the only award of childhood
that stays with you your entire life.
you go in the military, you can wear your eagle medal,
a special version of it,
when you're 90 years old and you die.
it's likely to mention the fact that you were an eagle scout.
it's not going to mention you were varsity football
or anything else you did as a kid.
it's attached to you your entire life
and to be cognizant of that fact
and to live up to it
is to be a true eagle scout.
that's the simple answer.
there's a more complicated answer
and
you know you've dealt with it a lot in your blog.
a lot of the people writing in commenting-
especially people asking for advice-
a lot of people write in and say:
you know, we decided not to let this boy
become an eagle because we don't think he's worthy.
that's that whole messy business
of
do you fit. the stereotype
of an eagle scout,
and that one
always bugs me
and I think it bugs most eagles.
I've found that people who are adults,
who are eagle scouts, are usually
a lot more flexible
about scouts becoming eagles.
I think you don't really
become an eagle scout
when they put that medal on you.
I think it's something that
you grow into over time.
as I think I've written to you
in the past,
nobody gets the eagle easy.
you become an eagle if you
earn the eagle
and you're serious about it.
you may finally become an eagle when you're 30.
you may do it when you're 15,
but
if you live the eagle life,
then you become an eagle.
that's a really good way of looking at it
and maybe it'll help inform people
who get a little exercised about this
every once in a while.
yeah, I'm weary of that.
we put enormous stress
upon these kids.
the sort of unwritten rule
that your eagle project
now has to change mankind forever.
that's an awful lot
to put on a teenage boy.
boys are ready to do their eagle project
and not a day before,
not a minute before,
a minute before. they're terrified,
they don't want to do it,
they don't want to deal with adults,
they don't want to organize anything.
and then one morning they get up and they decide
I'm going to do it,
and then they're focused and they pull it off.
was there anything in writing the book
that you discovered that
changed the way that you look at this at all,
or that you just were unaware of
and you thought was?
I think the thing that struck me the most
was that
eagle scouting
stands apart from boy scouting.
it's a classy example of being,
of scouting, but not necessarily
part of scouting.
once you start on the trail to eagle
beginning, when you become a life,
you enter into a different reality
and you move down that path,
and that path has been taken now
for a hundred years
by
for what? six million,
five to six million boys ahead of you,
and it's a fraternity
and it's filled
with like-minded people,
all of whom have decided
that they're going to go for something that's bigger
than anything they've ever done in their lives
and that's going to challenge them
in ways they can't imagine.
and I was struck
by that continuity,
that eagle scouting really is a thing
unto itself.
group of people that are
these kind of overachievers
and who did something this big
at such a young age.
they're going to cut their own path for the rest of their lives,
so you can't control them.
former members
who are still officially members,
who are presidents of universities
and Nobel Prize winners and Medal of Honor
awardees and members of congress-
they're a heck of a lot more powerful
than scouting itself
and I love that about it.
and when you go to an eagle court of honor
and they form the eagle court,
inviting everybody from the audience to come up
see these guys of all ages,
from their 20s to their 80s,
and you know it's colored their entire life.
everywhere you go,
you're going to run into an eagle scout
and he's going to be the guy
who's in the position of greatest responsibility.
and that's an amazing thing,
it's a powerful thing.
and writing the book,
I felt enormous pride
in this fraternity that I was part of
and felt compelled even more
to be an eagle scout,
to act like an eagle scout.
my prediction is
it's going to become the default
thing that you get for a new eagle scout.
well, thank you very much.
let me ask you this question
since I get asked it regularly.
right now the book's available in a kindle edition
and I know it's doing very well.
when are we going to get the
regular, good old fashioned hard
cover edition of it?
well, I can't commit to a precise date,
but I know that the publisher is creating an index
for it right now
and we're working with Neesa,
with Bill Steele,
in hopes that we can get
the photos that we want to put in the book.
so I can't make a precise commitment
or even a precise date,
but I think pretty soon
I would love to see the book available for Christmas,
but it is going to happen
one way or the other.
if I can help it, it will.
well, if I can help it, it would too.
I got a shelf of books
with my name on it
and I don't know how to file on the shelf
an electronic version of a book.
well, I still think.
when people have asked me
whether or not they can get it in a hard copy,
I tell them that
it's still a great gift for
a new eagle scout,
because that's usually what they're asking.
they want to get it for somebody who's just becoming an eagle.
they'll figure out how to read it,
even if we can't.
so
I'm watching the time here.
I've kept you a bit longer.
it's so much fun to read your blog.
I turned to it before
anything else from scouting.
I think your comment section
is brilliant.
you get a lot of interesting people
that are very committed to scouting.
that's probably the best part of doing it,
and I constantly take
your outdoor
lists, like the survival kit
you did the other day,
and I email it out
through our troop yahoo group email.
so
I'm glad to hear people find stuff useful.
that's good.
once again, the book's
4% the story of uncommon youth
in a century of American life,
and we've been talking with Mike Malone,
the author. thanks very much for joining us, Mike.
thank you, Clark, and best to all of
your loyal readers.
well, thanks so much
for listening to this edition of the scoutmaster podcast.
you can read the scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and when you go there you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
you can subscribe to the scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes and please leave
a comment or review a rating. we so appreciate it.
you can also access this podcast
on your mobile device through
Stitcher Smart Radio and get details
about how to do that. at stitchercom
you can call and leave a shout out
and you can find out how to do that.
go to scoutmastercgcom
and follow the shout out link.
you can also experience the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom through the vast
panorama of social media outlets.
we're on facebook,
at scoutmaster blog,
at scoutmastercg on twitter
and look for scoutmastercg
on google plus.
you can email me, Clark Green, with your comments
and questions and wild ideas
at scoutmastercg,
at ferizonnet.
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
it's just me with a microphone trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders
and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
before we leave you, let's hear from
Sir Robert Baden Powell. Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
thank you, sir,
until next time.